um please go past is a really simple
thing to say but if you go please go
past and you feel too close to the
person that won't work in anything that
you
do if you just go well I'm too close but
how do I get how do I actually get away
from them first of all you have to think
I don't mean anything to this person in
other words I
don't I don't wish to be in their path
and if you just think I don't wish to be
in their path you say please go past if
you say in a gentle Manner and a genuine
offering they won't feel threatened and
that's what really I've been doing in my
iido I've trying not to say I don't want
to threaten you the technique is strong
if I get it right then that'll be
powerful all right so anyhow I thank you
very very much don't mind I go my St